did i send you anything else to talk
about it oh well this this was a great
oh yes
yes yes i almost forgot
this is a new segment on the show do you
remember where are they now
remember that where they would find
stars
from your favorite sitcoms and uh
musicians
maybe one hit wonders or people you
hadn't heard from in a while
where are they now well we're doing it
again
this is the tim dillon show where are
they now this is from the new york times
they were guantanamos first detainees
here's where they are now i hope one of
them's a music manager and working with
demi lovato
let's see let's go to where they are now
oh man just two of the men are still at
guantanamo all right that's depressing
let's get rid of that i want to know
where are they now
who's improved
do they tell us not really one guy don't
tell us one guy they accidentally
released and he's like the leader of the
taliban now
why wouldn't he be here's where they are
now they're plotting against our country
for
good reason here's where they are now
they're
uh they're doing all the things we
thought they were doing before
that they probably weren't even doing
do they do they not give us an update on
anybody is there not one success story
is there not one person we tortured
mercilessly for a decade
based on dubious intelligence that came
out and now runs a weeds startup
is there none of that going on is there
not one bitcoin entrepreneur
nobody's big in crypto there's not one
of these guys who launched an energy
drink
when he was laying there being tortured
going i wish i had more energy
but they won't let me eat my food and
they keep waking me up every few hours
um you know which bush assured us was
necessary
and man i'd love to have an energy drink
right now so he came up with an energy
drink
is he having problem getting the first
round of funding
is the seed capital the issue
ben sol a law school professor in sydney
australia who in 2016 helped mr hicks a
guy named
david hicks is he the australian
uh convert to islam yeah they went to
australia he said he's working in
landscape gardening and had ongoing
physical and mental health issues as a
result of his treatment
by the u.s before and at kim i mean hey
man
when george washington said we should
not torture the british
we what a [ __ ] you know what i mean
what a [ __ ] i think it's a great idea
that we uh
started a labyrinth of underground
torture prisons
where we just rounded up people that may
or may not have been a terrorist
whatever that means and tortured them
mercilessly many of them like teenagers
in their late teens
and tortured them mercilessly for years
uh president bush instead of being
painting should be in jail right now he
should literally be injured
if it was a functioning democracy which
is we know it's not
he would be in prison he would be in
jail for this dick cheney would be in
jail
donald rumsfeld would be in jail but of
course it's you know
it's not and the barbecue in kansas city
sucks
so what's the point it sucks
because it's like tgi fridays it's that
sweet whiskey glazed sauce
i don't want to start i don't want to
start shooting on a specific restaurant
i'm not trying to hurt anybody making a
living
i'm just saying this austin's the king
of barbecue
i hoped in that article they were going
to tell us that a few of the people at
guantanamo bay
who we waterboarded uh were now running
a taco truck in
austin
i mean it's amazing remember that when
that came out everyone's like it's a
conspiracy
it's a conspiracy theory these people
talk less about discrimination than like
almost anyone by the way
people that you know where they should
be on snl
they should be on saturday night live
doing sketches doing bets because this
was one of the most disgraceful periods
of our country's history and we were all
sold it by 24 in jack power because he
was a ticking time bomb
well what happens when there's a ticking
time bomb
i don't know like a memo saying that bin
laden was going to strike and that they
were going to use planes and then
you had all the intelligence you had it
at the kuala lumpur meeting
with khalid sheikh mohammed and you and
norad and the jets ended up being
somewhere else in addition to that you
mean to one of those ticking time bombs
one of those oh i don't know
hmm tick tick tick
um but that's a great news segment for
the show where are they now
and i think this is just the beginning i
think uh the guantanamo mates are just
the beginning i hope
i hope that america can really embrace a
lot of the good that we've done
where are they now where are the kids
whose soccer games in pakistan we bombed
where are they now tell us where they
are now
where are they now how about the people
in yemen we've starved to death
because we keep it giving saudi arabia
money where are they now
but we don't like to talk about this on
snl because it's uh depressing
all right you want me to write some
jokes about uh imperialism
put me in coach i'll write you a bit or
two
you want me to go in there i'll tell you
i'll tell you what's
uh happening but um
yeah i mean where are they now
i didn't realize there's like 800 people
that have gone through guantanamo and
they're out now yeah
yeah well guantanamo is just this great
idea
um you know where we would bring people
that aren't guilty of anything
a lot of them literally many of them and
then torture them uh giving both
the by the way there was some
documentary where like a guantanamo
guard
could i think he converted to islam and
became friends with like one of the
dudes
oh really there's some documentary about
that that's how you know
what you're doing as a country is
working that's how you know you're doing
it's good when your guards are starting
to convert to islam because they feel so
bad
about torturing these people that's how
you know it's a great move
it's a good move and then bush is
painting at people in hijabs talking
about how much he loves immigrants
i never talked about how bad trump was
because he you know tweeted something
mean at megyn kelly
that that makes a lot of sense is this
them where are they now
are they now are they protesting the
closure of the echo park homeless
encampment
after initial after an initial period of
confinement they now live with their
families in housing provided by the
qataris they can move freely around the
cosmopolitan capital
the woman shop at local markets the
children study in a pakistani run school
but need
the blessing of their host country as
well as the united states and
destination to travel abroad
so they're on like house arrest kind of
the trump administration transferred
only one detainee and admitted al qaeda
terrorists who was sent to his native
saudi arabia to complete
a military commission prison sentence
under a plea agreement negotiated during
the
obama administration among the 30 yemeni
prisoners taken in by the oil state of
oman
were a blank blank blank he found work
in a factory married and is now father
to two children
i met how many people we just tortured
to death there
you know
like god only knows and by the way
guantanamo was the one we knew about
there was all these black sites we
didn't know about where people were just
getting tortured to death
yeah you know
well there you go folks that's the
government we all know and love
look at that isn't that nice i get it we
need a military we can't have terrorists
running around but also like you know
this doesn't seem to be the most
effective way to do it to bring in a
bunch of people torture them and send
them back into their countries of origin
to then come back and attack us now with
a reason
you know what i mean it's like let's
give him a reason
you know yeah you yeah 911
now we're gonna give you a reason we'll
give you a real reason to do another one
yeah
oh listen to this abbed al malik a
yemeni was sent to resettle in a
peaceful nation montenegro he received a
government stipend for a time after his
release in 2016 but that ran out
he tried to raise funds by selling
artwork he made it guantanamo
nft
but made his last sale last year and
as ambition to work as a driver in god
they're never materialized as the
tourism dependent
economy tanked that's sad
he wanted to be a guy like a tour guide
montenegro
it's sad like imagine him like he's a
tour guide in montenegro he's like it's
beautiful here
he's like and i should know the places
i've been
i mean he's just doing you know
four of those first 20 men all released
by the bush administration could not be
found
they're dead or we killed them or
they're doing things that
will lead to problems perhaps but
all right that's depressing enough i
just like to catch up on them where are
they now
i wanted more success stories and i'm
sure that there are more success stories
i think we're just probably looking at
the negative side of the picture i'm
sure there's a lot of people
that rebounded from that in a big way
and are
using what they learned to build a brand
and i hope they're all building brands
that's the question we should have gary
vaynerchuk
talk to people that would torture to
gitmo
and teach them how to build brands what
a great clubhouse room
garyvee tells you how to build a brand
when you wake up every two hours
screaming